(mellow smooth jazz music)
- Hello, I'm Bob Ross
and I'd like to welcome
you to the 29th Joy of Painting series.
If this is your first time with us,
allow me to extend a personal invitation
for you to get your
brushes and your paints
and paint along with us each show.
And if you've been with us before,
please allow me to thank
you for inviting us
back for another series of painting shows.
We'll use about a dozen colors,
some unorthodox brushes, and each show
I'll show you how to put some of nature's
masterpieces right here on the canvas.
So, I'll tell you what, let's get started.
Today, we'll have 'em run all the colors
across the screen, right there,
that you need to paint along with us.
While they're doing that, let me tell you
what I've got going on up here.
Today, I'm using an 18 by 24 inch,
double-primed, pre-stretched canvas,
but you use whatever size you'd like.
And I've just covered the entire canvas
with a very thin coat of liquid white.
Liquid white is designed just to make
the canvas wet, and to make it slick.
It allows us to actually blend color
right here on the canvas.
Makes your whole painting
life a lot easier.
So, let's get started.
Thought today we'd just do a very simple
little scene that hope you'll enjoy.
Let's start with a little two inch brush
and a touch of the alizarin crimson.
And we just load a little
bit right into the bristles.
Pull a little paint out,
tap the bristles firmly
to assure nice even distribution of paint
all the way through the bristles.
And let's go right up here.
And we'll take this old brush and just
making little X's, little
criss-cross strokes.
We'll just very quickly
drop in just a little
warm part in the sky, here.
Maybe we'll have a little pink in the sky.
I sorta like that.
And in our world, we can do anything
that we want to do here, any old thing.
There. Doesn't take too long when you're
using a brush that's two inches wide.
Okay, without even cleaning the brush,
we'll go right into, right
into a little phthalo blue.
(chuckles) I like phthalo blue.
It's a very warm blue, very nice.
Once again, just tap
a little color into it
and let's go back up here and still
using our little criss-cross strokes, X's.
That's all they are, little X's.
We'll just apply a little
bit of the phthalo blue.
Somethin' about like so.
Then we'll come back after we clean
the brush and blend that together.
Now, the blue is many many times
stronger than this little pink area.
It'll just eat it up, so be careful.
Be careful, all go away.
If you wanted to make the indication
of a happy little cloud, all
you do is just sorta tap.
Little stringy cloud
just lives right there
in the brush and that easy.
We'll blend him out, have a
little stringer cloud there.
Let's see, while we have that on there,
let's have some water in this painting.
I love water and it's very
easy to paint in this style.
Still water is always level.
And I think today we'll have still water.
So, pull from the outside in, outside in.
Somethin' about like so. Alright.
While I have that old brush going,
I wanna darken the corners a little bit.
I'ma take a little Prussian blue
and just add in the
corners here and there.
Little bit up there, and we'll go over
to the other side and add a little more
and then down toward the bottom,
and we'll put a little down here too.
I'm just putting a little Prussian blue
in each corner to darken it.
And then, the most fun part of this
whole technique is washing the brushes.
Since these are oil paints, we're washing
our brushes with odorless paint thinner.
Shake off the excess,
(paint brush thumps)
(giggles) and just beat
the devil out of it.
That's really the most fun part of it.
Now, with a clean brush,
and it's relatively
dry from just beating it, we'll start
in the light area, which is the pink,
and we'll blend it all together.
Somethin' about like so.
That's all there is to it.
Okay, and down here, we'll
just do the same thing.
There. But it's that easy, that easy.
What's so fantastic about
this is that anybody,
anybody can put a little
masterpiece on canvas
with just a little bit of practice,
a vision in your mind, and off you go.
Alright, that's working so well.
Take a little white,
little bit of the blue,
grab a little more of the titanium white.
I wanna make a light blue color here,
mostly phthalo blue, and let's just
tap a little color into the bristles.
This old two inch brush'll
do marvelous things.
Watch here, watch here, watch here.
It's fun. Take the corner of the brush
and just pull down,
somethin' about like so.
Straight down, straight down.
I wanna make it look
like little distant trees
live far back in the distance.
Little more color, and we'll just have it,
we'll go, I don't know, right there.
In your world, you create
any illusion that you want.
There, but I wanna keep the bottom light,
so it looks like mist.
You could even take another two inch
brush, I have several, and tap it.
Really get in there and tap
it and then lift upward.
It'll help create that illusion of mist,
right down at the bottom.
And sometimes, sometimes it's a lot
of fun to put several layers.
It helps create depth in your painting
and for that, we'll add a little more blue
but we make it a little darker.
Add a little Prussian blue to it,
make it a little darker,
but the same thing.
And we'll come back and just put
another little layer
in here, just touching
and pulling downward,
that's all we're doing.
That's really all we're doing.
Somethin' about like that. There.
And we don't know where that goes.
It doesn't matter at this point.
And back to our other two inch
brush, and we'll tap this.
I wanna create mist again.
Notice the separation.
It's caused because of
the difference in color,
difference in value, and that misty area
turns out to be your very best friend.
Take care of it, treasure it. There.
Okay, let's have some more fun. (chuckles)
Let's see, gonna take some black,
some Prussian blue, and
a little phthalo blue.
It doesn't matter, we'll
just throw it on there.
Crimson too, what the
heck. Be brave, be brave.
I'm gonna put a little
satin green in there too.
It's getting close enough we should begin
seeing some color. Little bit of white.
Don't want it totally dark yet.
There, perfect. 'Kay I'm
gonna wipe the old knife off.
And let's get us fan brush,
we'll use a fan brush.
Load it full of color,
both sides, both sides.
'Kay, let's go up in here
and maybe in our world
there lives, does now, some
little trees back in here.
Now, these are a little
closer, you're seeing
a little more detail, a
little more distinct. There.
And we just drop 'em in.
We don't know where they
go, wherever you want 'em.
That's exactly, exactly
where they should live.
Don't put too much detail in here.
It's too far away, you're not
gonna see a lot of detail.
You see detail when
it's very close to you.
When things are far away, you make out
form, shape, basic color, that's all.
Save the detail till the foreground.
The lack of detail helps also create
that illusion of distance
and depth in your painting.
It's very very important, very important.
M'kay, I'm gonna tap a little of that.
That'll help create that
illusion of mist on there too.
There. Lift slightly upward, lightly.
Just a little bit, see? Now then.
You know, when I was a traditional painter
one of the hardest things to make
effectively was reflections.
Watch how easy, I'll take
some of that same color,
we'll take a two inch
brush, touch and pull down.
Just pull straight down.
It's most important that
we go straight down.
Somethin' like so, straight down.
(clicks tongue) make those little noises.
Then, very lightly, go across. There.
And instantly, we have some
nice reflections, that simple.
Now, here somethin' is funny.
Take a little, I just use a little white.
If you wanna create another
plane in your painting,
take a little white and lift upward,
and it'll make little areas back here
that looks like a whole different plane
and the white will look like
little trunks in those trees.
There, that easy.
Let's put a little water line.
For that we use liquid white.
Pull it out very flat,
flat as you can get it,
cut across, 'kay?
And we can go right up in here
and we can just drop in
just a little water line.
Just a happy little water line lives back
in here somewhere, we
don't know where it is.
Don't know that we even
care, just let your
imagination take you
anywhere you wanna go.
Lotta times I start a
painting and have nothing
in mind but the time of
day and the time of year.
And from that, you can paint
some fantastic little scenes.
Don't worry about it, you don't always
have to have a perfect vision in your mind
of what it is you're gonna paint.
Imagination is, it's like any
other muscle in your body,
or lack of muscle in your body.
The more you practice,
the better it becomes.
Take some black, Prussian blue,
I'ma put some phthalo green in there.
I like phthalo green,
maybe a little crimson.
There we go.
Alright, let me wipe off the knife.
I just wipe the knife on a
little, little paper towel.
I would just use that
brush, little fan brush.
Load some color into it,
both sides of the brush.
Both side, let's go up in here.
Let's have, let's have
a little evergreen tree.
He lives right here, see?
Just make a line, take the corner
of your brush, make a
touch, make another one,
and just sort of work from the center out.
There it goes. (clicks tongue)
It's easier to do 'em fast
than it is slow, though.
Here they come. (clicks tongue)
Just sorta back and forth.
I had a lady in class one time tell me
it was like makin' Z's, the letter Z.
She called 'em Z trees, so I guess
that's as good of analogy as any.
From the center out,
the center of the tree
should be the thickest, darkest,
strongest part of the tree
'cause you have leaves on the back,
you have a trunk in the middle,
and you have leaves on this side.
We'll have one more in there. There we go.
Have a little family of trees.
You know if you've painted with me before,
I think everybody should
have a friend, even a tree.
Even a tree needs a friend.
Now, if you wanted to reflect those,
just pop in some general indications
of where they are, no big deal.
'Cause we don't make mistakes here,
we have happy accidents.
Very quickly, you learn to work
with anything that happens.
Take the big brush, pull
down. (clicks tongue)
Straight down, once
again, and then go across,
and we have instant reflections.
I'ma just use that same fan brush.
It has that color we
made the tree out of it
and I'll go through cad yellow
and a little yellow ochre.
Immediately, we have green.
There we are. Let's go up in here.
And we can take that green, let's go back
and put some highlights on our little
evergreen trees, there
they go. (clicks tongue)
Alright, this little tree here he's sayin,
"Don't leave me out. I need some too."
There we are, there we are, there we are.
Alright, now, gonna put
a little liquid white
right on that same brush, 'cause I wanna
lighten the color and
make it a little thinner.
A thin paint will stick to a thick paint.
We mix 'em back up again,
just go back up here.
And we can just take this brush
and let's just pop in the indication
of some little bushes that live down here,
right down in these little foots.
Somethin' about like that. How's that?
That looks like a little island.
Let's put some dirt there.
Let's take some white, little dark sienna,
mix 'em together, cut off
a little roll of paint.
Let's go up in here and we'll take this
and we just put the indication here,
a little bit of soil,
some dirt, some kind.
Gotta have a little place, if this is
a little island, for all this to sit on.
Alright. See there?
That's all there is to it.
M'kay, (sucks teeth),
alright, we gotta figure out
somethin' to do on the other side now.
Let's have some fun, let's have some fun.
You know if you've painted with me before,
I like old big trees.
Let's take a little bit
of that color right there,
let's go right up in here.
This is your bravery test, take the corner
of the old two inch brush and let's just
begin laying in a basic shape here.
Tree it lives right there, right there.
Big old tree, but he's a nice tree.
There he is.
Alright, while I got that brush going,
I tell you what, maybe let's do somethin'
about like this. (clicks tongue)
And we just tap in all kinds of little,
little bushy lookin' areas.
You have to decide what lives here,
how far it goes, how tall
is it, how short is it,
it's fat, skinny, in
between, it's your world.
And in your world, you
make all the decisions.
All the decisions. There we are.
See, we're just puttin' some dark in here
so later on, our light color will show.
We'll just grab a--
(paint brush clatters)
Oops, grab another one.
There's a fan brush right there.
Take a little white, a little
bit of the dark sienna,
just wanna make the indication here.
Maybe a little tree trunk,
maybe a little more dark sienna.
(exhales quickly) That's nice.
'Kay, right here. (exhales)
Just want some indications.
I'ma put some happy
little leaves in there,
so we're gonna cover most of those up.
Most of 'em won't show,
we'll go right into that.
Need a little sap green,
little bit of the yellow.
We'll just put it right on this
two inch brush, give a little push.
Good shot there, you can see that well.
'Kay, let's go up in here.
Now, I wanna put some leaves on here.
Use just the corner of the brush,
just the corner of the brush. There we go.
See? That's all there is
to it, just the corner.
Think about shape and form, drop these
little rascals in wherever you want 'em.
Wherever. You really are the creator
on this piece of canvas.
You can do anything!
You can move rivers, mountains,
create any illusion that you want here.
When I go home, the only power
I have is over the garbage.
I can take it to the street all by myself,
but here I can do anything,
absolutely anything.
I decided I wanted a bush right there.
And, tell you what,
let's get crazy.
You know me, if you've
painted with me before.
I like big trees and we have one
living in our world right there.
There he comes.
We should've done this
with the two inch brush,
it'd been a lot faster. There we go.
Just drop it in wherever
you think it should be.
Alright. Boy, that's a big tree,
I wasn't kiddin', this is a monster tree.
Huge tree and you could've done it
with a two inch brush just
as easy, but much quicker.
I like the old fan brush, it
gives you a little more detail.
Here we go with a smaller tree,
'cause I think he needs a friend.
There. 'Kay, just drop it in.
All we're doing, once again, is putting
in the background color.
You could put this in with a paint roller,
it doesn't matter, long
as the shape is right.
We'll come back and separate all
of this with some nice highlights.
Here's a little brown and white.
We're gonna put the
indication just here and there
of a trunk, just what you
can see, here and there.
There. You don't see
it all 'cause you have
leaves on this side.
We can go back to our little fan brush,
go right through the cad
yellow, yellow ochre.
We'll load some color into it.
Let's go back up in here.
Let's put a highlight or two on here.
Evergreens are normally
darker than other trees,
so don't kill all the dark
here in your evergreen.
It happens sometime,
get's ya' feeling good
and you don't know when to stop.
There. And the base of the tree should be
darker than the top, big
shadow areas underneath.
And those shadow areas are where
all my little friends live.
In previous shows we've had, like Peapod
the pocket squirrel, my little
squirrel that lives with me.
We've had him on the show.
But this is kinda the
places that he likes.
Let's take a little bit of color,
let's use the, let's
use the one inch brush.
We'll go through some, get some sap green,
some yellow, load a lotta
color into the brush.
More sap green. (sharply
exhales) That's nice.
Alright, then we can go up here,
and we can begin picking
out individual bushes,
one at a time, one at a time.
There's a happy little
bush, lives right there.
You knew he was there, didn't you?
And he's got a little friend named Clyde,
lives right over here, there he is.
So you can give all these things names,
personalities, it's okay.
We'll take the little oval brush,
dipped in some paint thinner.
We'll go through some
midnight black and some brown
on one, wanna load it full of color again.
Then I'ma take, and with the other side,
I got some light brown I made earlier.
I'm just gonna go through, see?
Like that, put a little black in it,
make it a little dark, ooh that's nice.
Now, with that I guess we'll come up here
and make the indication, we can't see
too much of 'em, of some
rocks that live up there.
Just some happy little rocks.
Maybe there's one
(exhales) there, somethin'.
Wherever, just some indications.
Then we'll come back with our brush
we were making the bushes with
and we'll settle those right
down into the painting.
There, now see?
Now they become part of the painting.
There we go, just like so.
And we'll make all kinds
of little bushes and trees
and happy little things
that live here in our world.
Alright.
Okay. Shoot, if we had
such a place as that,
I'd have to go fishin' there.
I like to fish but I'm
not a very good fisherman.
I catch a little fish and
take the hook carefully
out of his mouth and
put a band-aid on him,
little CPR, pat him on the toot toot,
and put him back in the water,
go back, catch him again another day.
But we'd have to have a way to get up here
if we're gonna catch that fish.
We'll take a little of the van dyke brown
and let's have us a little path.
We had to walk all through
through these bushes,
maskeeters would get us, so let's have us
a little path that we
can walk back in here,
catch a big old trout or bass, whatever
it is that lives in here. There.
Take a little bit, let's find some white,
little dark sienna, mix it together,
make a little highlight color.
Just barely touching, barely.
Let it graze, let it graze.
That easy, that easy.
'Bout like so.
M'kay. There.
Now then, let's put
somethin' on this side.
Ya have somethin' on
the other side the path,
now let's go on this side.
Once again, I'ma take a one inch brush
and I'm just settin' it straight down
and I'm pulling it in one direction.
It's most, most important.
That loads a lot of paint,
and see it rounds one edge.
You wanna turn it, put that
rounded edge to the top.
It's most important.
Then we take that, we go right up in here,
no pressure hardly, just enough to get
the brush to touch the canvas,
and we begin working on shape and form
and we create a bush or
tree that lives right there.
That's all there is to it.
And there's another one,
but do one at a time.
I know, I know. Sometimes it
starts working, you get greedy.
Do one at a time, one at a time.
I'ma put a little bright red on there.
Maybe here's one right here. Oh, yeah.
It's got little, I don't
know if you can see 'em,
I got little red flowers on the tip.
(chuckles) Sneaky. There.
Then we can go back over in here,
and we can begin adding in just little
things that come about here on the path.
'Bout like that. Alright, alright.
You got your brushes warmed up yet
and you're ready, you can do this!
You can do this, I know you can.
I get letters every day from people
all over the country
that said they'd never
believed they could paint
and they're doing it.
Their friends and
neighbors don't believe it
when they look at their
paintings but they are doing it.
There. I'ma put a little stick
lives right there, little old tree.
Maybe, maybe, maybe this little tree died
and he's naked now, just a
skeleton hangin' out here.
And that happens in nature.
There. So, we can put little arms on him
that are still hangin' out. Alright.
All kinds of little dooders.
Maybe over in here, and
these little details
are what'll make your painting
look a little more finished.
Take your time when you're doing these
and just drop 'em in here and
there and there and wherever.
Take a little light brown
with paint thinner on it
and when you mix this, get it very thin.
This should be almost like,
almost ink consistency.
Turn the bristles, that'll
bring it to a very sharp point.
There you see it good
against that dark, alright?
And where it's very dark, then
we make little light trees.
Where it's light, we make dark trees
because they both exist in nature.
So you can put little, see now there's
a little tree lives back
here, just has a good time,
looks out over the
water, talks to the fish.
That's all there is to it.
Another way of making
little sticks and twigs,
take your knife, just a clean knife
and you can reach up in here and just
scrape right through the paint, see?
And that'll make all kinda little sticks.
And let's come down here,
we'll make a few more in here, wherever.
You decide where they live.
Sometimes, these old evergreens here
have old dead limbs hangin' off of 'em
and you can do that, just with
a little flick of the knife.
And shoot, with that I think we
'bout have a finished painting.
It's that easy.
Let's take a little bit
of the paint thinner,
little bright red, and we'll
sign this little rascal.
Really hope you've enjoyed it.
It's a very simple
painting that you can do
and if you try it, I'd love to see
some photographs of what you're doing.
So if you have time, take a photograph,
send it to us, let us hear from you.
Until then, from all of us here,
I'd like to wish you happy painting
and God bless, my friend.
(mellow smooth jazz music)